cause like there's pictures of like Elon
with uh gazelle Giselle giselle's Lane
Elaine Elaine Gillette Gillette
[Music]
we've got a very very very spicy article
here submitted by one of our lovely
patrons
we have Waymon C2 thank you for
submitting wave Aussie too if you're
watching right now we have a little
phone live streaming right there because
all of our patreons they can watch so if
you guys are not on patreon you're not
here with us spicy just means sexy now
no spicy just means it's hot that's all
I thought spicy only meant sexy [__] now
I'm not trying to just say spicy for
sexy I'll say sexy for that one spicy
I'm just trying to like have anything
that's kind of yeah I think it's a
little well extra okay yeah so um this
one is about naming the name it's a
final batch of documents containing
salacious allegations related to Jeffrey
Epstein yes bring them out including
prince Andrew will finally be made
public after dozens of John and Jane
does agree to the unsealing of it yo
there's already some stuff that's coming
out even though they haven't released
this like the bang what you heard okay
so the bank CEO or the Barclay CEO he
was got he got caught like with the
emails going back and forth with Epstein
talking about oh I want this girl and
then they would give like code names of
uh Disney princesses like I want Snow
White make sure you bring her for me and
whatever so it's clearly like he's
definitely was a pimp like he's pimping
girls out it's there's no secret
this may be a semi hot take but I wasn't
as mad at everyone that wanted to see
the list
everyone's like oh dude give us a list
they're [__] lying their [__] butt
I'm not a cop I'm not an investigator
but if I'm running some [__] and I'm
actually trying to catch people to give
our FBI and CIA a little bit of love if
they're really trying to do that [__]
they can't release the list because then
those [__] are gonna hide yeah
that's true so I don't mind if they're
doing their job which of course we will
never know but if they're doing their
job I don't mind that the list has been
kind of hidden because yeah you
compromise the case the Barclay guy's
gonna go buy an island and disappear but
I think the problemo is they you could
already see all the fumbling the ball
fumbling so with the security guards
[__] falling asleep Epstein kill
themself and then there's no like actual
prosecutor like hey I represent the FBI
we're gonna [__] get these
[__] I agree I agree we just
see ball fumble after uh I'm trying to
think positive all right and and
how Legacy
like it doesn't even like why does no
one want to talk about it that's the
weirdest thing but if they come out and
start reading the list like Barclays and
[__] first name it'll literally
shatter all our hearts on that list
because I've seen little pictures of it
it's like all our favorite actors you
know like Eddie Murphy been on that [__]
like everybody Chris Rock everybody been
on that plane like that sucks Lolita
Express they're literally just gonna
disappear right yeah again given the CIA
the benefit of the doubt but I also
don't know who who [__] the underage
girls who just rolled the plane like we
don't know or who's hanging with him
because he's Rich yeah because I bet he
was that guy yeah he was probably he
made it
how many times have we been in proximity
to people where later you find out that
guy was a complete [__] face and we had
no idea or like you might have even
taken a picture like you're at a party
and you're chilling and you take a
picture right because like there's
pictures of like Elon with uh gazelle
right gazelle giselle's Lane Elaine
Elaine Gillette Gillette I like gazelle
better
she's like that razor company right yeah
so yeah there's like photos like that
all the time and how many pictures have
we taken at networking events [__]
meet and greets whatever right and any
one of those [__] faces could have been
a sleaze ball I agree I think most
people think that like oh if you hang
out at a party you know all this guy's
dirt life don't work that way no not
really no and imagine all the times too
like you you go to a giant party and
you're at this party but you know even
though you're seeing the same people
that you always see at parties doesn't
mean you're invited to the circle that
goes to the bathroom that does the
cocaine right you know what I'm saying
you might not be associated with that at
all we're the losers or you might be the
drug dealer but like either way you can
all still be in the same party with
people that are squeaky clean yeah it
doesn't Define like how close they are
to friends to you yeah yeah you know
what I mean that's why I think Chris
Rock didn't do a thing well because the
list is that just the flight log or is
that like the [__] I think the list
that got leaked already like year ago
was the flight log I think so yeah but
you don't know right then Chris Rock
supposedly did community service with
them in Africa but
documents uh include or related to 167
of Jeffrey Epstein's Associates victims
and employees
um this will be unsealed nearly four
years after the disgrace financier's
death the material will be made it's
been four years damn covet bro is a
black hole right yeah who we could for
sure know was doing some shady [__] My
Boy Bill Clinton dude he was all for
Billy dude Williams those logs dude he
was everywhere everybody was like yup
bill was there yeah bill
are we surprised if Bill Clinton's a
pervert like he's been caught so many
times how old was Monica when that went
down wasn't she the intern she was the
intern yeah dude bill was all over that
but even before that like just there
were there's been so many rumors of him
being a naughty boy so like
can we just put him and his wife in jail
then
he put Hillary in jail
there was that whole thing going down
during um The Campaign it was called
Clinton Body Count yeah because the
clintons were supposedly like killing
off political opponents and people would
mysteriously die Hillary's people bro 30
people it was like 30 people all her
interns disappeared and they're not just
interns they're bodyguards just in their
proximity like U.S attorney generals
there's 30 people in their proximity
just car crashed fell off the road that
[__] is crazy deaths are like really
freaked deaths died by pigeon attack 30
of them yeah that's just [__] weird
bro yeah hit with Morningstar yeah but
those playing hopscotch and the Earth
opened oh James the Clinton the Clinton
Body Count conspiracy theory is on
Wikipedia yeah no it's huge yeah it was
a big because there's like 30 people and
people don't talk about it
got smashed by a dump truck dude yeah
it's a lot of stuff I love how like just
uh by you know the way that it's so
clear the Clinton Body Count is a
conspiracy theory asserting that former
U.S President Bill Clinton and his wife
former U.S Secretary of State Hillary
Clinton have secretly had their
political opponents murdered totally as
many as 50 or more or 50. yeah that's a
lot that's [__] a lot many parts of
it have advanced by a news I've been
through a lot of [__] death and it
ain't been 50 folks yeah that's true
like that is a lot that's as many times
as Bill Clinton has been and this is
like back in the day now they're old so
yeah all your friends gonna die but this
is back in the day this is before they
were like old yeah and the only the
people that are the closest to them
right and it's like Final Destination
Deaths they're not like freaking oh all
of them died of smashed by a log all of
them are Final Destination Deaths that's
also wild Bell through an escalator yeah
I wish I knew like all the real [__]
about people in power like because right
now all we get is conspiracy and maybe
hearsay from someone that might be close
to them right but then
um we don't really know what their world
is what they do what kind of shady [__]
they get into because like they're never
gonna be open and honest about any of
this stuff because we've been given a
facade like for for ages like but them
all in the circle they all know I think
if you knew though no one would believe
you because I think it's so crazy even
that number 50 people died that directly
worked for them that sounds fake you
know what I mean but I watch House of
Cards and I can believe it now we need
our boy Alex Jones to take over as
president yeah at least don't cancel the
Internet it's half a joke
he's funny I don't know probably right
about a lot of the Clinton stuff I don't
know he's right about some stuff that's
not all of it he's an Entertainer not a
reporter or whatever you want me to say
YouTube
I voted for Hillary are you happy go
Biden
[Laughter]
throw me in the algorithm or something
that's what blows my mind too is like
they've been doing this hustle with like
the Democrats versus Republicans like as
if they're actually not on the same team
yeah yeah for
ages no growing up I thought Bush and
Clinton wanted to kill each other and
then they're in every party together
kicking it yeah all the time yeah
kicking it that's what blows my mind I'm
like dude you guys know they're all
sponsored by the same people yeah
I wish that they um had jackets of all
of their sponsorships just like NASCAR
drivers yeah that'll be cool because
then you would not shave club [__]
Pfizer yeah yeah but they're all like
shitty sponsors had no idea better help
both of you guys
dude all these photos have you have your
boy uh all these photos have your boy
prince Andrew in them he's got what all
these photos have your boy prince Andrew
why are you saying my boy dog I don't
even talk about it that much because
you're royalty dude oh [__] that's
that's smooth bro well you know it's
because you're my king
so like you know we watch like Game of
Thrones and like all these dramas right
and then like kings and queens are like
[__] trying to take power there's
like all this [__] Espionage and
people [__] each other like if that's
happening just like in every day in
companies and stuff like that what makes
people believe that it's not happening
at a higher level yeah yeah I think
people don't even think that's happening
at a lower level that's why but we've
seen it happen everywhere it's happening
at Target bro yeah like you go to
[__] Walmart and then the store
managers [__] the the clerk yeah yeah
yeah yeah and they're trying to get one
[__] fired and it's like yeah you ever
hang out with like people that work at
Trader Joe's they got some crazy stories
you know they got some crazy interwebs
of like like what Joe said of like
managers other staff yeah or tried to
[__] me last week
yeah or hospitals too the staff and
hospitals oh hospitals are wild yeah
it's a hot thing yeah what do we do just
go hide somewhere I don't like this this
stuff creeps me out I know what the the
corruption just all of it yeah where are
we safe because it's gonna happen in
other countries too it's not just us hey
if you can't you know what is it if you
can't beat them just [__] him who's he
gonna [__] next
I don't know
I would hope that the world is getting
better and I think with the internet
what it is doing is now people are
having conversations and it's sticking
because I think like let's say in the
90s or even in the early 2000s right
your your view of the world is only
through like TV and you didn't have
access to people having conversations
online now yeah I don't really like
welkness but a piece of wokeness is that
a lot of people distrust a lot of things
like government or they're questioning
it for the first time ever in their
lives right so now
um because of that you don't have Legacy
Media just brainwashing everybody so now
there's other people being brainwashed
in different ways but at least they're
questioning it now true
I think that's that's all we can hope
for is people
um slowly
changing by seeing different information
yeah people got to be loud about it so
people pay attention like my boy prince
Andrew like they're not they're they
talk about them too much I don't really
like that like Freedom you know what I
mean free him
he's a he's the biggest prince Andrew
supporter here he loves the Royal Family
Man five minutes ago I was like why do
you I don't even talk about him that
much
laughs